smallness of increasing families
for the invitation is my great pleasure
and honor to give a talk in this
prestigious Workshop so I'm going to
talk about peace monies of increasing
families and when I Was preparing this
talk I was more I think I was too much
ambitious I put too much stuff in the
slides and and yeah on one end I thought
my talk is gonna be one hour which is
longer than my usual talk but on the
other end I just heard at the beginning
yeah
uh so I should make
um my talk shorter than I then I planned
so yeah probably I'll not I'm not going
to be able to cover all of the stuff on
the slides but rather let me go slowly
and I'll be staying here until Wednesday
so if I don't cover everything on the
slice then I'll be very happy to talk
about uh the those uncovered things uh
during outside of this talk
okay so let me start from some basic
definitions so here we use x for a
finite set and let me see if I can use
okay but I like my fingers so we're
gonna use x for a bin I said and two to
the X for the subset of X and the
picture that I have in mind whenever I
imagine 2 to the x is this so this is 2
to the X with the natural process
structure we have the empty cell on the
bottom and X on the top and for example
in the first layer we have all of the
singletones and Etc and we're going to
use our calligraphic f for an increase
in family or increasing property if it
looks like this so This Means whenever
we have an element in F all of the
supersets of this element are also
contained in F so that's the definition
of an increase in property
and we use mu P for the P bias product
probably measured on 2tx 2 to the X and
we're gonna use XP for the random
variable whose distribution is Mu P so
this means XP is basically a p random
subset of X which means we pick each
element each element in X with
probability P independently so you can
see that whenever we have we are given a
set a in X then the probability that XP
is equal to a is precisely mu P of a
which is defined this way
and so we use mu P of f for this um
obvious meaning so this is the sum of
all of the MU P measure of a for a
inside f and what we know is if an
increase in property f is not the empty
family or the entire family we we call
this a non-trivial family in this case
mu P of f is if p is zero then mu P of f
is zero because if p is zero then this
empty set has measure one so in this
case if f is non-trivial then mu P of f
is zero on the other hand if p is one
then mu P of f is one because in this
case X has measure one
okay so this is what we know and do you
have any questions about this basic
definitions
okay
so a well-known so let me talk about
fresh let me give you the definition of
thresholds
um or well known fact is that for any
increase in family f as long as this is
non-trivial Mu P of f which is by
definition the probability that XP
satisfies the given increase in
probability F this is continuous and
strictly increasing in P so in the
previous slide we just checked that when
p is zero then you P of f is zero so we
are here and when p is one then you P of
f is one so we are here and SP increases
from zero to one u p of f also increases
from zero to one and because of this
there must exists something called PC of
f for which mu P of f is exactly
one-half and this PC of f is called the
threshold for f and if you're familiar
with uh the earliest rainy random graph
then probably you are more familiar with
the notion of Elder's range threshold
function which is defined this way but
because of a theorem by bolobosh and
Thomason we know that this definition PC
of f is always on average Humanity
threshold function so in this way
because of this we can replace uh we can
use the notion of the threshold for the
place of the aerodynamic threshold
function so from now on we're going to
use the definition for the threshold
um in the rest of the talk
yes
there's some result that it's like sharp
if it's a graph property right by an
email and Network free good then oh yeah
that's so much sharpness of thresholds
and that's about the rate like how how
fast or how how fast this graph is
growing so that's not but our concern is
mostly mostly about the location of
expression okay yeah so I mean that's a
very interesting area but so because we
have we just have 50 minutes
okay do you have any questions
uh okay so peace moon is our main
character in this talk is p smallness
and I'm gonna give you the definition of
p smartness after like several slides a
couple of slides but let's start with a
motivated example first
so uh in this talk our convention
conventionally we're gonna use small c's
for small constants and Big C's large
consonants but basically I'm going to
ignore constant vectors so I'm gonna
just care about the order of the
magnitude
and in this motivating example uh the
bracket n is the collection of the set
of integers from one up to n and our
ground set X is n choose two which is
the collection of all of the edges in
the complete graph k n so in our friend
2 to the X picture the picture looks
like this so this is 2 to the N choose
two and at the bottom this is the empty
set which means we have an isolated
vertices so in our setting n vertices
are just there as a default and each
element is each Edge in the complete
graph so the complete the empty set
means and isolated vertices then what
are The Singletons the single tones are
um the graph on N vertices graphs or on
N vertices with a single labeled Edge so
we have a graph with h12 a graph with
h13 Etc so can you imagine you can you
can picture the structure of this post
set and on the top we have the complete
graph k n okay
and then here okay so if our X is n
choose two the collection of all of the
pairs on N vertices then in this setting
XP is just a GMP the earliest rainy
random graph so GMP becomes one specific
example of this P random model and then
what are examples of increase in
families so one example is to contain a
triangle this is an increasing property
and if we draw a picture of this
property in this picture then
this is an increasing property and all
the minimum and elements consist of
labeled triangles so each we have each
triangles and F consists of all of the
graphs that contains at least one member
in this minimum elements and then
another example of an increase in family
is to be connected and in this case what
are the the minimum elements
what are the minimal elements there is
yes not those trees but labeled spanning
trees so we have all of the labeled
spanning trees and F consists of all of
the supersets of those minimal elements
okay so this is the picture that I have
that I have in mind
and so yeah again this is a motivating
example and our question is when the
given increase in property is to contain
a perfect matching so the picture looks
like this it's the minimum elements are
all of the labeled perfect matchings in
this case what's the threshold and so we
know that there is so we can find on a
lower amount very easily using the first
movement method
so in this case we know that the
threshold is at least some constant Over
N or one over n is if we just care about
the order and this is because if we let
y to be the number of perfect matchings
in GMP this is a random variable
the expectation of Y is by linearity of
expectation we can compute this
expectation by this computation so this
is the number of perfect matchings in KN
the complete graph times P to be the
number of edges in a perfect matching
which is n over two so we have this
quantity and this quantity tends to zero
if p is much smaller than one over n so
from the definition of threshold we know
that the threshold for this increase in
property must be at least as large as
one over n so from here we have a lower
bound on the threshold
so this means I just reiterate what our
observation this means if p is smaller
than 1 over n of the constant Vector
then this guarantees that mu P of f the
probability that GMP satisfies the given
increase in property this is small and
here I should I should quantify what
this small means but let me not do that
but here small means for example is
below the cutoff for the threshold but
it's just small so it's away from one
so what I wanted to say is so from this
like obvious example I wanted to give
you a two quick reminders the first
reminder is the first moment method
provides a naive way to find P for which
mu P of f is small so it's kind of like
a certificate that guarantees mu P of f
is small on the other hand the converse
is not true but I I put quotation marks
in the converse because I didn't make it
rigorous but in this context the
converse means even if we know that mu P
of f is small that doesn't guarantee
that this first first moment for this p
is not is small
so we know that in this example the
threshold for containing a perfect
matching is log n Over N so that means
if p is in between 1 over n and log n
Over N then in this range mu P of f is
still small because we have to load the
threshold but the expectation when you
look at this computation the expectation
tends to the infinity when p is in
between 1 over n and log n over n so
this tells us that the converse of this
first first moment approximation is not
always true
so okay then let me give you the
definition for the piece monies uh this
peacefulness is introduced by the Khan
and Kawaii in their paper thresholds and
expectation thresholds but they didn't
exactly name this property as P small on
the other hand the name is introduced by
Telegram in his paper like in several
papers and one of the papers is are many
small sets explicitly small and here he
um so in this paper he concerned many
different random models but if you just
focus on the P random model then this
small means u p of f is small and this
explicitly small means kismo so in the
previous example I hinted that like okay
let me not do that let me let me
continue in the next slide
so this is the definition for the kids
smallness and uh from now on we're gonna
use f for non-trivial increase in family
always and uh let me introduce one more
definition so here for any g a sub
family of 2 to the X the bracket G is
defined to be the opposite generated by
G and I think it's better to use the
picture to introduce them to give or
introduce the definition so here those
purple dots are the elements in G and
for each element we take the superset of
this element and then we take a union of
all of the supersets this is so this
shaded area is the opposite generated by
G is this okay
uh okay and then this is a definition
for t smallness so we say on increase in
family f is p small if there exists a
family g into the x that satisfies the
following two properties the first
property is for any element a in F there
exists another element B in G such that
a contains B
with this means this increase in
property f is contained in the offset
generated by G and in this case we say
that g covers f
and the second requirement is oh okay
let me give you an example first so for
example if our increase in family is to
contain a perfect matching just like
this then an example of a copper G is
the collection of all of the labeled
perfect matchings so in this case if we
take this guy our cover G so if you take
this guy G then you see the f is
contained in the offset generated by G
so in this case G covers F but of course
there can be many other covers so and
basically G leaves below the given
increase in property F and if we are
clever then we can find many other
different covers
so this is the meaning of the cover and
then uh f is p small if G satisfies this
property so this is so we first consider
for each element B in G we consider P to
be the size of B and you see that this
p2db is basically uh the the MU P of the
Shaded area for each single tone so if
this is p then this if this is B then P
to DB is the major mu P of this area and
then we want the summation of all of the
measure of this offset of each element
is small it's at most one-half
so basically what is what we have on the
left hand side is the first moment with
respect to the given
um collection G do you see this because
P to DB is the probability that b is
contained in x t so if we add them up
then this gives us the expected number
of elements in G that are contained in G
okay so this is the first first moment
computation and we want this first first
moment to be small
okay so from this definition we have
this easy observation which says that if
f is p small then it guarantees mu P of
f to be small
this is because
um okay so if fsp is more then f is
contained in this sum cover and the
first moments for G is small which means
the summation of all of the Shaded area
so the summation of measure of all of
the Shaded area is small and because f
is contained in the opposite generated
by G so there that guarantees u p of f
is also small so this is like more like
a very naive certificate or to guarantee
that VP of f is small just like our
first moment computation in the previous
slide yes this seems like the container
method but for p bias oh
[Applause]
yeah
okay well I think it's basically the
difference is in the container method we
want the number of containers to be
small but here we don't know the
probability
oh yeah sure so yeah so this is okay in
that sense this is similar so we want UK
to be small and this is one way to show
to guarantee that is not okay yes what
year was this a coin Collide was 06 so
what year was this telegram paper what
year was the tollywood paper oh that's a
good question okay we can check oh no
it's not oh okay
with o6 right so okay so this paper
mentions can't Collide connector so this
one is later than this one
okay
okay on the other hand this um I I don't
know this this bonus is already
mentioned before this paper so probably
promotional peace movies comes before or
they are independent I don't know okay
sorry
uh okay so
so the final remark is this peaceful the
notion of peacefulness gets stronger for
larger P because if p as P gets larger
this inequality gets harder to be
satisfied okay so if it's small then
it's easier to say to be satisfied well
p is larger then it's hard
um uh okay so this was the notion of his
bonus do we have any questions
and I hope I gave you I showed you the
connection between pismonis and the
first movement computation so basically
we want to bound the measure new P
measure of f using the first movement
computation that's what all happens here
uh okay so
um
when you have like just some fixed graph
and you do the um V minus one e minus
two thing isn't that's basically like
some primitive notion of P smallness
right like like you know the threshold
to contain some random fixed graph as
you look at the sub graph and you look
at this yeah this is basically a proof
of notion of Peace moments right yes yes
exactly yeah so this is
here so I think I think what you just
mentioned is here okay okay
so before we move on okay let me let me
just give you I think okay maybe some of
you are already familiar with emotional
peacefulness but probably some of you
are not so I would let me just spend two
more slides to give you more tangible
examples for peacefulness so here this
is the this is the definition for
peacefulness and in the first example we
consider the increase in property of
containing a K4 so still our ground set
is a random graph
and I claim that this increase in
property is n to the negative two thirds
small so in the first example we are
going to show how to show that the given
increasing property is something small
and in the next example I'm going to
give you an example that how can we show
that something is not something small so
in this direction so how can how can we
show something it's something small in
this case what we what we want to do is
to find a proper cover
so in this case when f is this then F
looks like this all of the minimum
elements are the labeled k4s and in this
case one obvious cover is just to
recollect all of the minimum elements if
this is our G then obviously this G is a
cover of f okay and in this case so G
satisfies the first property and in
number two if we go over the computation
in number two so as I said this is the
first moment computation so basically
this computation is the number of k4s in
the complete graph times P to the number
of edges in K4 so this gives us n to the
four times P to D6 this means we ignore
the constant vectors
so this sum is small if p is below
something times n to the negative two
thirds so this tells us that if we take
P to be n to the negative two thirds
times some small constant then uh this
number two is satisfied so does f is
this quantity small so basically this
means our first moment computation gives
us this value and as long as p is that
then it guarantees that mu P of f is
small
okay so again this implies WP of f is
small four P smaller than this
okay
and then in the next example uh we take
our increase in property to be to
contain a perfect matching and I claim
that f is not e Over N small where e is
the Euler constant 2.78 something
something
so then how can we show something is not
P small so in this case it's enough to
show that for any coverage G of f any
copyright G
if we compute this sum so this is the
first moment computation that I promised
in number two so if we show that this is
at least one half for any copper then
this tells us that e Over N is too large
for f to be this small does this make
sense
so if we can show that this one is this
one exceeds one half for any given cover
that we are done
okay
so first of all we may assume that g
consists of matchings because F looks
like this so the minimal elements of f
is all of the labeled perfect matchings
so if our cover contains something
non-metrics then then that element does
not contribute anything to cover an
element in F so we can just kick that
out so we may assume that g consists of
some matchings okay and then one quick
one Elementary exercise is if we are
given a labeled matching say B then if
we compute to the ratio or the numerator
is the number of perfect matches in the
complete graph that contains the given
labeled matching B and divide this by
the number of perfect matchings in k n
the total number of perfect matchings
then this is at most e Over N to D the
size of B
elements G is anything something below
this minimal element s of that
and so it does give me a hint of this
exercise so for example if our B just
consists of one single edge let's say
this single edge is labeled one two then
what's what's this ratio this ratio
means what's the ratio perfect matchings
that contains the given h12 and what's
the ratio this is about 1 over n because
once we fix this Edge then we lose about
any other choices
so that is so that's why we have 1 over
n to the size of B here does this make
sense so if we fix two edges then we are
going to lose N squared many choices
and once you believe this Elementary
exercise then we can show that this left
hand side the first moment computation
so we can replace e Over N to DB by this
ratio so we have this
and then now we use the fact that g
covers F that means all of so in this
summation each perfect matching is
counted at least once
okay so this summation is at least the
number to total number of perfect
matchings so we have at least one so
this gives us
um or the conclusion that F cannot be e
Over N Small E Over N is too large to
for make to make or F to this Pismo
uh okay so this is one way that we can
show that something is not piss small
and if you're familiar with this topic
then probably you know the notion of P
spread which gives an upper bound on P
smallness and you'll notice that
basically the notion of spread is a
wasted version of this ratio but again
because I have limited time so let me
not go into that details but here I just
wanted to give you uh show you that
there is there is a way to give an upper
bound on a p smartness and we use this
kind of ratio or weighted version of
ratio
are you okay so far
any questions
am I going to pass
you're saying one sentence that you can
relax this to a linear program and then
the Dual is yeah it comes at the end
yeah that's true okay but yes yes so
that has to do with the notion of
fraction expectation threshold and
that's a fractional relaxation of his
smallness but I said I gave you some
free print at the end yes thank you for
the car okay any other
questions or comments
okay
so yes okay
um so so far uh one thing that we
discussed is if f is p small then that
guarantees that mu P of f is also small
then so there are so there are some
conjectures of telegrams so Michelle
Telegraph he made thousands or millions
of conjectures and these are just some
of the countries so it's this is so I
can't say this is telling us conjecture
because there are so many conjectures of
him but some of the conjectures of
telegrams concerns about this this type
of problems so he or he were interested
so he care about a certain increase in
families not every increase in families
for certain increase in families and we
know that somehow we know that
mu key of those increasing families is
small
and then he asked then can we say that
this F is also P small
so we know that the opposite is true
because of that line so we know that if
f is p small that that guarantees that
mu P of f is small so basically his
question asks the opposite direction it
is the converse true and then in in the
paper like small in his paper he
mentioned the he wrote this line so
practical minded reader will ask what
use would such a result have and might
not share the author's feeling that it
would provide fundamental information so
I think it depends on your personal
taste whether or not you agree that this
type of question gives us fundamental
information but in this talk I'm going
to introduce some practical aspect of
this of or practical aspect of this line
of questions and I prepared three
different problems that has this flavor
that that evolves into this line of
questions but probably I will not have
time to talk about everything but let me
just say like the first two maybe I will
have time to talk about the first two
things but if you if you're interested
kid then I'm very I'll be very happy to
talk about the storage one
uh okay so the first one is the
expectation threshold theorem it's
formally the conclave conjecture and so
again let's start from some simple
example so let's say ffh is the increase
in property of containing a copy of H
and by a well-known result of erdog and
rainy and bolovash we know that for any
fixed graph H the threshold for this
increasing property is equal to a
constant up to a constant Vector the N
to the negative 1 over rho of H where
rho of H is the maximum density of a
subgraph of H just like Rayo mentioned
Ryan happy
okay so we know this is a well-known
result
so this are
okay so and here there are two
directions to show this so first we know
we showed that this one is a lower bound
on the threshold and then we have to
show that this is an upper bound on the
threshold and the lower amount is easy
because we uh by the first movement
computation whenever we have a fixed
graph H this increase in property is
this small so this is an easy direction
from the first moment computation and
the harder direction is showing the
opposite but anyway this result gives us
a positive answer to the the tolerance
question do you see that because this
result tells us that for any fixed graph
H if we know that mu P of this increase
in property is small that there then
then they guarantees that F of H is
Pismo
so and so at least a poor uh that
increasing property for h a fixed graph
we know that we have a positive answer
tolerance question
and but we know that this implication is
not true for General H and one
well-known example is a perfect matching
so in in few slides I'll go we saw that
or if if p is between 1 over n and log n
Over N then the u p of f is small but
that is not P small so in general this
star is not true and then the
expectation threshold theorem implies
that even if this throw statement is not
true by reducing P by log H we can make
this statement true so that's what is
implied by the expectational threshold
theorem so again this result is in the
line of televised question
uh okay so this is a formal statement of
the expectations threshold theorem and
uh okay
so and this theorem applies not just
applies to the graph
um setting but it applies to more
abstract settings so we back to the
general X and increase in property F and
for given F we Define qf to be the
maximum key where f is p small so as I
said this piecemon is gets stronger as P
gets stronger so we take the maximum key
that makes F to the P small and this one
is called the expectational threshold
and then note that this qf is still a
lower bound on the threshold because
whenever we have F to be P small then
this P gives us a lower bound on the
threshold
okay and then what we proved or with
them is this so there exists a reversal
constant K such that for every finance
that X and increase in property F this
threshold which is at least uh qf is
actually at most qf times log of L of f
where L of f is the size of the largest
middle element of f so in particular it
says that if L of f is constant then
there is no Gap up to constant Vector
between the threshold and this
expectation threshold so this says that
really will be small is implied so
really peace monies not just P smallness
implies mu P of every small but the
converse also holds if as long as L of f
is a constant
okay so this is one result that is in uh
in this in the line of taliban's
question and
uh okay so in this slide let me let me
post some related questions so as I said
the expectation threshold theorem
implies that for any age if we reduce P
by this log Factor then mu P small
implies Pismo which is the harder
Direction and then one open question is
can we find or can we characterize H for
which this implication holds without the
log modification
so in this case we know that this is
true when H is fixed and there are there
is another very interesting example that
makes all this implication true which is
or the case power of a habitude cycle so
in this case the case power of a
Hamilton cycle is a spanning graph so
here log H becomes log n but actually in
this case
um we can we have this statement without
Divine P by log Factor so this statement
is true for this case power of
hematocycles
oh so that means so for example the the
square of a Hamilton cycle means we
start from heriton cycle and then we
connect each vertex to each second
neighborhood so cake power just means it
connects to case neighborhood so that we
use case power over Hamilton cycle is
again expanding graph so that means if
we just rely on this theorem that we
must have log n but we can actually show
that we can push harder and we can
actually show that there is no no login
vector
so this is another example that gives a
positive answer to telemann's question
and then by generalizing the argument in
Canary Island Park on Sam Superior also
gave a sufficient condition for this to
hold for a spanning graph but we don't
know whether this sufficient condition
is close to a necessary condition so one
big open question is can we characterize
H for which this implication holds
okay so this is the end of the first
question but do we have any questions
I think I'm going a little bit faster
because I think many of you have seen
this before so let me not spend too much
time on this so
is there a lot of like in this kind of
when you say these graphs do you use
actual symmetries of graph or it's just
very abstract about fully unconscious so
this serum itself does not rely on the
graphic property there's no symmetry at
all and in this uh in this work I don't
think we use metric but we do use some
like or so we do use analysis on spread
so there's no symmetry requirement but
we have to look at or we have to compute
spread what about this
yeah I believe so he it doesn't rely on
the graph structure because because I
have a look at this very carefully but
but I know that his results generalized
extended our results so I believe
there's no signature requirement
okay any other questions
okay so then let me move on to the next
uh problem which is about random
assignment
so here yeah I believe also people are
familiar with random assignment but let
me start from the beginning so what do
you say what is an assignment we start
so this is a two-dimensional assignment
we start from n by n read M and then it
so we have N squared entries and each
entry m i j they are assigned IID random
variable explanation of whose
distribution is exponential one
and then on assignment means the
collection of pairs I Sigma I where
Sigma is a permutation so basically this
means in each line we see exactly what
occupancy so this is the meaning of an
assignment and then each entry has some
numbers on it and then the quantity of
interest is this
so we look at this assignment and then
we sum the cost on in this assignment
and then we we consider we are
interested in the minimum cost of the
assignment this is a very natural
question right so we can view like we
have n tasks and then we have n machines
and this occupancy means we assign this
task to this machine and then in each
assignment we have the cost of this
assignment and then we we are curious
about what's the minimum cost for for
all possible assignments when the cost
is given aside by this in this random
way
okay and then yes this is a very well
studied question since 1960s and it was
conducted that this minimum expectation
wise this minimum should tends to pi
squared over six and then this result is
already Pro it was it was proved by all
those in 19 in the combination of the
two papers and then actually much more
is known so after this by two
independent works we know that this
expectation actually is equal to the
summation of I to the negative two which
tends to pi squared over 6 as n tends to
the infinity
so we know so this is a very well
studied question and then once we know
what happens in two-dimensional thing
then the next thing is to care about
higher dimensional thing so we we can
also
think about higher dimensional
assignment and if you look at the two
dimensional assignment then there are
two Metro extensions one is actual
version that we talk about now but there
is also a planar version but let me not
go into the details in that so there are
a lot of interesting work in planar
version of the random assignment but let
me not go into the details because we
don't have so much time
anyway so this actual version is this
now our ground set is n to the D so this
is D dimensional assignment and again
each entry so we have n to the D many
boxes and each entry has IID exponential
one random variable and we say s is an
actual assignment if s meets each axis
parallel hyper play hyperplate exactly
once so in this picture if we just think
about three-dimensional assignment then
we have n many hyperplanes and we never
look at each hyperplane we see exactly
one occupancy that's the meaning of on
our actual assignment
yes
exponential distribution uh I okay or
it's not okay so in terms of the result
the exponential distribution is not very
important but we we do need some nice
distribution and and I think in this
context considering exponential
distribution is very natural
but eventually our result is is using
uniform distribution because that's that
was more convenient for us but I think
there's no big difference between
explanation and the uniform okay are
there any questions any other questions
uh okay
so again the quantity of interest is
this what's the minimum cost of this
random assignment and so for for Gravity
let me call this quantity z d z d of N
and then it was proved by a freeze and
circuit that this minimum cost is
between entity negative D minus two and
N to the negative D minus two times log
n
okay so and unlike the two-dimensional
assignment this ended so if we go on to
this higher dimensional assignment we do
not know the exact value of this zdn we
just know the order and the exact
constant is not known yet as far as I
know but I want to talk about why we
have this lower bound and this upper
bound because it's nice
so if we just think about b equals three
in this case our ground studies entry
three so we have the phrase with three
dimensional box and this claims that Z3
and this is between 1 over n and log n
over n
and this one is easy
because just forget about an assignment
and just think about we fix one
hyperplane and then what's the minimum
cost of all of the cubes it's more or
less 1 over N squared because we have N
squared many cubes and then because we
have this nice distribution so if we
take the minimum then it will be around
1 over N squared and because we have n
hyperplanes so if we add add up all of
the minimum um costs then it will become
one over n so did the cost for the
assignment should be at least for the
brand does this make sense
and then this upper bound comes from
much harder result so this comes from
shamirabound by Johansson Khan and Boo
and so for this Opera to derive this
upper mode we need to change our
Viewpoint so instead of considering an
actual assignment okay
actually n cubed this can be viewed as
this three uniform
um complete typograph so we have n
vertices and vertices and and vertices
and the n2d3 is basically three uniform
on a complete a three-partite hypergraph
because we can view this one as our x
coordinate
and this is why coordinate and this is z
okay so this one becomes this complete
graph and then what is an assignment in
this complete typograph an assignment is
just a perfect matching
right and then Johansson Khan and whoa
that their result says that if we
collect edges or if we collect the end
times login many edges at random from
this complete typograph then typically
we have a perfect matching okay and in
terms of the weight that means if we
collect all of the edges of weight at
most log and Over N squared
then typically we have a perfect
matching which means we have an
assignment there was the cost of the
assignment that's at most this times end
so we have this upper bound
so we have this log and gap between the
lower bound and this upper bound and
then what we proved with Frankston
narayana what we what we showed is the
law about is the truth
okay then how can we do this and this
has to do with telegram's question so
basically
what happens is this so in this question
we can we translate this question into
this increase in property to setting of
increasing property and our universe is
2 to the N to the D so n to the D is our
first our set and we consider the power
set on n2dd and our increasing property
is the offset generated by all of the
assignments
and so in this example what free store
can use is for the upper bound is this
vet so they used the fact that if mu P
of f is close to one which means if we
are likely to contain a perfect matching
then this the cost of your assignment is
bounded above by n times P so this P
corresponds to the maximum weight that
we choose and then this n comes from the
number of hyperplanes so they used this
obvious fact but here the hard part is
to find out what is new P because when
mu P of f is close to one and that comes
from Johansson Khan will result
and then so for convenience if we take
the Contra positive of this statement
then what we have is if z d n is at
least something then mu P of f is away
from one which means small
and then what we showed is this but let
me not read the the rigorous statement
but if we apply so this is gotten by
combining the result the proof of
Frankston Park and the proof of Park fam
it doesn't come from the statement
itself but if we combine their proofs
techniques then what we have is we can
replace this conclusion but by
um Pismo so this conclusion says mu P of
f is small but then we can replace this
by piece more so basically this again
this is in the line of telegram's
question we know that something is for
some we know the MU P of f is small but
what we showed is this is actually
principal
and in reality why is this useful the
reason why this is useful is now because
we have peaceful in this conclusion so
we can replace this assumption in this
contrapositive form we can replace this
assumption by f is not P small
how does that affect the result in this
absorption we want P to be large enough
so WP of f is large and that requires P
to be log n Over N log n Over N squared
but if we just want p f to be not piss
more then that means p is above the
expectation threshold which is 1 over N
squared so instead of using log n Over N
squared we can use 1 over N squared and
that gives us the conclusion that we can
remove this log Factor so replacing mu
Pismo by Pismo really helps in improving
the bound and getting the optimal amount
okay so it's obviously but do you have
any questions
we also need the park fan oh so if we
use the express bandarian part maybe
what we have here is weekly Pismo
which means yeah we we can we can show
that this is not P spread yeah but if we
combine go to results maybe we can get
kids
oh yes just for the bound we don't need
Pismo we just need weekly yeah because
they have the same balance in general
like fknp works are pretty much all
practical applications you guys call me
yeah that's coming okay are there any
other questions
[Music]
oh I don't think so I don't think there
is a conjecture about the constant
Factor yeah but I think the two case
there was a nice formula right yes yes
so I think in this case the motivational
purpose circuit was because so the first
step to get the precise asymptotics is
to get the rice to get the right order
and the right order was only approved in
2020 and there was there is no conductor
for the constant Factor as far as I know
yes
any other questions
okay so as I promised let me skip the
last part but let me go into this
summary and uh connection to the
professional version of the calculator
reflection expectation threshold so here
uh this is a summary so we were
interested in television so we
introduced several or a couple of
results that are in
um this televised question are many
small sets explicitly small so here the
question is well we know that new P of f
is small can we also show that this F is
also peaceful and by showing this we
have some nice results about
in practical purposes
and so this has to do with Ryan's
question so Q of f is the maximum P for
Which F is p small but in applications
we need to Upper bound this Q of f we
need a good upper bound or optimal upper
bound on Q of f so the question here is
how can we operate on Q of f and for
this one known Result One known way to
give an upper bound is using spread and
I gave you a hint of giving an upper
Bound in like several slides we can use
the ratio
and so in terms of that telegram also
introduced Q star F which is called
fraction expectation threshold let me
now give you the definition of this one
but this is kind of like a fractional
like relaxation of the definition of
expectation threshold and because of
that definition we have that Q star of f
is always an upper bound on the on two
of f
and then if you use LP Duality then we
can show that uh having an upper bound
on the fraction expectation threshold is
equivalent to saying that there is some
like output spread measure on the given
increase in property
and so this connects the amazing
breakthrough of always love that we
enjoy about sunflower conductor and the
fractional can Collide on conductor
which also has a huge impact on the
study of threshold anyways and also the
integer version of the concili
conjecture due to myself and who it with
them also is also inspired by this
connection so this was so this was very
nice connection and so what is very
interesting is so far all of the
applications use its spread measure to
Upper bound Q of f so that means this
upper bound is kind of like indirect
because we use an upper bound not on qf
itself but on Q star of app
so so that means as Ryan pointed out so
this means so far as far as I know all
of the applications just follows from
this weaker version of telegram's
conjecture oh this fractional can color
is actually conducted by telegram so he
has millions of contactors
and so now another conditional telegram
is this so can we say that can we show
that or what is the truth for the gap
between qf and Q star f are they
actually equal so this polygons
conjecture says that they are equal up
to a concert vector and I think this
conductor is very interesting if either
we prove this or disprove this if we
prove this conjecture then that means
having spread measure is an optimal way
to give an upper bound on the
expectation threshold so there is no
other no better way than than
constructing spread measure to demon or
promote and if we disprove this
conjecture then probably that means
we'll have another way to give a better
upper bound on directly on qf rather
than giving an upper bound on the spread
so I think this this conjecture is
interesting in many sense and thank you
very much
the conjecture ah
which conductor
non-fraction of the thing up to a
constant yes I do and I have some
partial results and there are still
progress being made but yeah skilled
that the entire projector is open so I'm
not sure about yeah I I want to believe
that if there is a counter example does
it have to be weird in some way
do you have any results at this time oh
weird Define weird it's up to you
but you know if like it's some grass
property yeah eventually that will be
very like a whole new approach review
requires of new ideas because so far as
I said all of your applications uses the
spread and that already gives us an
option Bond so you also want so like
some recent result is
or something like that like that's you
know I in some sort of special case
where app comes from some ground
property has a nice symmetry
that comes from some sort of graph
property can you prove it or some sort
of
you know like if there's a counter
example for example symmetry yeah yeah
sure
so I mean so one lesson we get from the
resolution of the company conductor is
symmetry really does not health okay so
I don't know
sorry but that was a very good question
and yeah I will be very happy if you can
prove that are there factors of
operations
you mean here
uh you're lower balance okay so okay
what we know is because we already
solved the the chair and which and from
there we can get that few star athletes
at most constant times qf times log l
and from there we can get some upper
bounds on the constant vector
we have some like silly hormones but I
don't think this is more examples which
I'm curious if you have time to just
show us the product Escape that's right
just maybe show us so the couple of
slides so the third part
now it's not probably part of the doctor
so
you're curious about this one uh now
everybody if you are you know I mean
yeah I can do that but maybe during the
break like let people go out if they
want and then I can only continue what
do you think doing lunch everyone's just
gonna leave
it's not four minutes
but I was advised to finish before it's
an optional advice
who is happy with looking at this part
okay thank you very much oh thank you
for being very nice okay so this is
called natural Telegram
but it still requires some time to
explain what it is okay so we go back to
the general situation so our ex is just
any finite set and experience of X and
in this setting we consider a family of
weight defined on X so those are
non-negative weights and let me draw
picture
in three minutes
thank you
so the situation is this let's say this
is our
um ground ZX and then we we have a
family of weight that are defined on
this finite set X so let's say we have t
so our family consists of many many ways
let's say t is a weight defined of a
single function of X then negative
weight and then we have another weight
that are again depied on the same
buttons on X and then we have so many
other which defined on the same buttons
okay so we considered different ways and
then the quantity of interest is this so
we pick XP you know from our Concepts
so this is our XP and then we look at
the weights on this random Choice XP and
of course we have for each different
weight we have different weight on XP
and they will reconsider the Supremo of
the automation of the weight is this
situation clear
okay and then again so just give you
some more tangible example
if our girls at X is n choose two the
collection of edges of the complete
graph and let's say our weights are
defined by the indicator of a perfect
matching which means whenever so this is
our closet and whenever we have a
perfect matching
then the weight means on this on these
matching edges we assign one and on the
other edges we assign zero and we do
this for all of the different labeled
perfect Matrix so the size of our family
is precisely the number of different
perfect matches this is clear and in
this case
what is this quantity supremum
observation of Pi
this is simple information number of GNP
because we look at the maximum matching
so I just wanted to show you that this
is not like some strange quantity this
is very familiar
and then so this is what I proved to be
preferred in 2022 again this is another
context here on telegram but I feel like
I repeat that
so what we showed is this so here we
consider the event this is the event and
let me
recycle this picture is this we will get
it's not that s of this x and the
property that is satisfies is this if
you look at the weight on this s and if
you look at the supreme or maximum of
the summation of weight on this set
we want this summation of the weight to
be larger than the expectation much
larger than the expectation
so this is the event and of course this
event the collection of this event will
P of this event is small because of
markov's important right and then what
we showed is this is ecologism
okay that means okay this conductor
maybe but what okay I like this
repopulation more and I think at least
to me this repopulation is more like
interesting because they're equivalent
but this is more intuitive to me so this
is a little bit multiple so let me not
read all the details but I can I can
tell you what happens here so the
situation is
basically you're saying weighted
matchings are supposed to be small
oh and stuff like that so it's it's okay
so let me explain this so again this is
our ex and in this big formulation the
situation is we have some
collection of subsets
and then what happens is in each subset
we have
weight defined so let's say this is X1
then there is
non-megative weight defined on the
single tools inside S1 and increases S2
then there is a weight that is defined
on the single Tools in S2 so that means
even before the same element if this one
is contained in different family
different subsets then this one has
different weights depending on its
affiliation
in this case the conclusion says that if
this if p is over P so large so it's
above the expectation threshold for this
family so this family
T is large so that this is not
case mode this means p is of both the
expectation threshold of this family
then if we pick a random subset XP then
there must exists number States is
expectation wise there exists submember
as I so there is intersection has
constant fraction of the weight defined
on that side
okay just to tell you this is not
something strange okay let's think about
the perfect matching example then what
it says is okay so a familiar example is
in order to contain a perfect matching
what's the threshold we know that it's
login over n
on the other hand if you just want to
contain like 90 of the perfect matching
what peat we need
constant or n
so this says that so we we if we are
above this expectation threshold then
our XP contains for some member XP
contains a constant fraction of the
entire weight
so this is already well known for a
perfect matching example but in this
case it's much more General because we
consider General weights defined on each
thing each set
NSI okay so this is the result and again
what we showed yeah so for this one what
we showed is to replace up small by
piece mode that's what we did and again
this proof is inspired by the sunflower
breakthrough thank you very much
[Applause]
lunchtime